JOHN: Good morning,
and welcome to Talks
at Google in Cambridge, Mass.
Today, it is my great pleasure
to introduce Marc Abrahams.
It's not every day
that we get to welcome
the man "The Washington
Post" has called the nation's
guru of academic grunge,
who's also a manga hero,
but here we are.
Mark's CV is far too
long to list here,
but we know and love him
as Co-founder and Editor
of "The Annals of Improbable
Research and the author
of "This is Improbable"
and the book,
which we're
expecting imminently,
"This is Improbable Too."
Not to mention Co-author of "The
Ig Nobel Cookbook, Volume One,"
which frankly sounds terrifying.
And of course, he's
the Founder and MC
of the Ignoble Prize Ceremony.
Little known fact, he's married
to psychologist Robin Abrahams,
who writes the "Miss
Conduct" advice
column in the Sunday
"Boston Globe" magazine.
I love that column.
Maybe you do, too.
If any of you has
a friend who has
a personal problem
or a social issue,
I'm told that Robin
would welcome your input.
All the questions that come
to the column are from readers
and she's always
looking for those.
So without further
ado, please join me
in welcoming Marc Abrahams.
[APPLAUSE]
MARC ABRAHAMS: Thank you, John.
Thanks very much, John.
My name is Marc Abrahams.
I am editor of this magazine.
It's Called "The Annals
of Improbable Research."
Some of you are very
familiar with it.
Some of you probably
have never heard of it
and are even on
the verge of being
offended at what it might be.
I'll distribute a couple copies
in our most traditional manner
here.
I've got a couple more later
on if anybody would like some.
I collect things.
I collect research.
And I define that in the
broadest possible way.
I collect research that makes
people laugh, and then think.
These are real things
that are documented
that when you first
encounter them are funny.
There's something about
them that just is funny.
But also, there's
something about them
that a week later you find
it's still rattling around
in your head, the
kind of thing that you
want to tell your friends
about and argue about.
So if it has both qualities,
it makes people laugh
and then think, I want
to get a hold of it,
put it in our magazine.
I also write a
newspaper column in one
of the British newspapers
with similar things.
And I write other places.
And then, every
year we give prizes.
And that's mostly what I'm
going to show you about here.
This research, I
hope you will agree,
deserves to get
some kind of prize.
[LAUGHTER]
Let me show you another.
This is a piece of a patent that
was granted in 1965 to George
and Charlotte Blonsky.
The Blonskys were
a married couple.
They lived in New
York City at the time.
They invented what they call
a device to assist women
in giving birth.
This is what it looks like.
It's a large, round table with
some machinery underneath.
When the woman is ready
to deliver her child,
she lies on her
back on the table.
They strap her down
to the table and then
the table is rotated
at high speed
and the child comes flying
out through centrifugal force.
If you look closely at
this engineering diagram,
you may decide that there is
at least one suboptimal thing
in the design.
I would point you especially
toward the part of it that's
designed to catch the
child when it emerges.
You may feel that
that's not quite
adequate to the task,
what they've got there.
And I'll show you
a third thing here.
This is a biology paper.
It was published in a biology
journal in the Netherlands.
And it is the first
scientifically documented case
of homosexual necrophilia
in the mallard duck.
This won an Ig Nobel
Prize for this.
This was completely
unknown to ornithologists
when it happened.
Each of those things I just
told you a little bit about
has been awarded
an Ig Nobel Prize.
And the prizes have that same
criterion that I described.
If we've chosen well on
these things, each of them
makes people laugh
and then think.
We have been doing this
every year since 1991.
We just had the 24th First
Annual Ig Nobel Prize Ceremony
two weeks ago.
You work with at
least one person
who is vital to our-- let's
call it an enterprise.
Quentin Smith, who I
think some of you know,
has been our broadcast engineer
on the webcast for the past six
or seven years.
When he began, he was
an undergrad at MIT.
And we've been webcasting
that ceremony since 1995.
We were, I'm pretty sure, one
of the very first things ever
to webcast anything.
Robert T. Morris, who some
of you know that name,
was our first
broadcast engineer.
He was also I believe
the first person
convicted on federal charges
of doing something that
caused the entire
internet to collapse.
It was not something
he was trying to do.
He's a very nice guy.
We have a nice history of good
and interesting engineers.
I'll tell you a little
about the Ig Nobel Prizes.
First of all, this
word "hiccups."
You may see it repeated here.
I hope you do.
Otherwise, you have maybe some
kind of problem not related
to hiccups.
But hiccups, hiccups, hiccups.
There is form of hiccups
that lasts a long time.
Not just for a few
minutes or a few hours,
but it goes on for
days, weeks, and months.
It's rare, but it does happen.
The medical profession calls
it intractable hiccups.
They have names-- nice official
names for pretty much anything
you can imagine
and lots of things
you probably couldn't imagine.
Doctors have never known how
to treat intractable hiccups.
They've tried lots of things.
Finally, a few years
ago, somebody-- a doctor
in Tennessee came
up with what seems
to be a reliable cure
for intractable hiccups.
He tried it and he
published a medical report.
Here it is.
He calls it "Termination
of Intractable Hiccups
with Digital Rectal Massage."
Are there any questions about
any of the technical terms
that I'm using here?
Francis Fesmire is the
doctor who did this.
We awarded him an Ig Nobel
Prize in Medicine for this.
Here he is giving
his acceptance speech
at the Ig Nobel Prize Ceremony.
Since that time,
other doctors have
seen his report,
other doctors who
had similar patients that
they were trying to treat.
And they have tried his
method and so far every case
we've heard about-- a
small number of cases,
but every one we've heard about,
the method has worked reliably.
I have some unhappy, some
very sad news to report.
Dr. Fesmire died a few
months ago unexpectedly.
He worked at a large
medical center in Tennessee.
And we've seen the
obituaries, and his colleagues
are very sad.
He was, obviously, a
beloved, in many ways, man.
I'd gotten to know
him fairly well.
He liked to come back every few
years to the Ig Nobel Ceremony
and do what you see here.
And he told me that
one of his dreams
was that someday he would be
able to travel around with me,
especially when I go
to Europe and do events
with some of the Ig
Nobel Prize Winners,
that he would come
along and he'd
be able to explain his
technique to people
around the world as part
of an Ig Nobel event.
But he died and that's
never going to happen.
So I would like to
ask a little favor,
even though you don't know
me and I don't know you.
Would you please join me just
for a moment in a small tribute
to Dr. Fesmire?
Could you raise a finger
in honor of Dr. Fesmire?
Thank you.
All right.
So this again is the
criterion for things.
And it's just this.
It's got to be real and it's
got to make people laugh.
People anywhere.
People who aren't
familiar with it at all.
If it's going to win
an Ig Nobel Prize,
make people laugh
and then think.
We get something like 9,000
new nominations every year.
And we-- and we is
a lot of us, mostly
volunteers-- are always
looking for things, too.
But we get floods of things.
Little floods
coming in every day.
And we give just
10 prizes a year.
And they're not necessarily
restricted to recent things.
We can, by our own
rules, go back up
to about 50 years or so.
As long as there's somebody
still alive who knew the person
and could come and
talk about that, then
it's OK to give that a prize.
The oldest we've ever given,
or the farthest back we went
was about 15 years ago.
We gave a prize to
the three people
who were responsible
for naming Murphy's law.
You know Murphy's law, that
great engineering principle
that if something can
go wrong, it will.
And that was born in an
engineering project that
happened at Edwards
Air Force Base, which
had a slightly different
name back in the late 1940s.
An incident that happened there.
And it involved Captain
Murphy of the US Army Air
Corps, whose name ended
up in Murphy's law,
and several other people.
Murphy's son came
to our ceremony.
One of the co-winners
was the leader
of the project which led to the
birth of the name Murphy's law.
And it's somebody
who hated Murphy.
And it's somebody who devoted
the rest of his life trying
to convince the world
that Murphy gets
too much credit
for Murphy's law.
If you win an Ig Nobel
Prize-- first of all,
before I explain
this, in most cases
we will get in touch
quietly and offer the prize.
And if somebody declines the
honor, if somebody says no,
that's fine.
And that's the end of it
and we never tell anybody.
Happily for us, almost everybody
who's offered an Ig Nobel Prize
decides to accept.
And here's what they.
They get an Ig Nobel Prize.
That's what you're
looking at here.
It's a different
design every year.
They're always made of
extremely cheap materials.
This is from last year, 2013.
And the design that year was
a frame with a glass front.
And under the glass, there
was a hammer and an indication
there-- a statement,
"In case of emergency,
use hammer to break glass."
So you get that.
You also get a
piece of paper that
says you've won
an Ig Nobel Prize.
And the piece of paper is
signed by several people
who have Nobel Prizes.
So it's a nice piece of paper.
And there is a tradition that
a lot of the winners follow.
And they seem to keep inventing
it independently, too.
They'll take this piece
of paper home with them
to whatever country they'd come
from to come to the ceremony
and put it in a
nice frame and then
hang it in their home
right above the toilet.
We don't have any money, so
we can't offer cash, alas,
to the winners.
Just because we don't
have cash to offer.
But we did finally figure
out a way, even on that,
that we could overcome
that limitation.
This past year each of the
winners received $10 trillion.
Each of the winners,
each of the winning teams
received a $10 trillion
bill from Zimbabwe.
You may remember Zimbabwe
had a little incident lasted
about a year and a
half with inflation.
And they were--
by the end of it,
they were printing bills with
a face value of $100 million.
The government
official in Zimbabwe
responsible for doing that
was awarded an Ig Nobel Prize.
He, at the same time,
was having a government
print some bills that had a
face value of $100 trillion
and other bills that
had a face value $0.01.
And he published
a book to explain
to the public in Zimbabwe
and the rest of the world
why he was doing this.
And he said that when you're
spending these large amounts
of money, you still
have to make change.
[LAUGHTER]
If you win and decide
to accept the prize,
you are also-- the
other thing you
get is an invitation to join us
at the Ig Nobel Prize Ceremony.
This happens in the
building you're seeing.
That's Sanders Theatre, which
is about two miles down the road
here at Harvard.
It's the oldest and biggest
meeting place at Harvard.
It fits 1,100 people.
It's always completely
jammed up on Ig Nobel night.
The tickets sell
out very quickly.
And as I mentioned before,
we webcast it live.
Have been doing that
for a long time.
And you can see videos of
many of the past ceremonies
on our website, improbable.com.
The very best thing about that
is you get to see these people.
And you get to see the
heart of the matter, too.
The winners are kept very
secret until we introduce them
on stage.
They come, many of them
from quite literally
around the world.
And at their own expense.
We defray it with the
$10 trillion bill,
but that's all we can do.
And when we introduce
each of them,
they step out through
a curtain and waiting
to greet them is a
Nobel laureate who
will shake their hand and hand
them their Ig Nobel Prize.
And one of my colleagues is
with me today, one of the people
who helps all of that work
on stage, Eliza Kosoy.
Eliza, if you wouldn't mind
standing and taking a bow.
ELIZA KOSOY: I'll curtsy.
MARC ABRAHAMS: A curtsy.
A bow, whatever.
[APPLAUSE]
So Eliza is one of
the people who's
in charge of making
sure that the winners
and the famous scientists
and all don't panic on stage.
That they have every
reason to feel comfortable,
and in good hands, and
that they have a good time.
And will go where
they're supposed
to go without having
to worry about that.
And it usually
works out just fine.
This year's prizes
were two weeks ago.
I haven't had too
much chance to do
a proper gathering of
materials from that.
So what I'm going to show you
is a little bit of what happened
there, and then I'll show
you a little more detail
about the prizes we
gave out last year.
This is a little piece of
video from two weeks ago,
from the ceremony.
This will show you one
of the winners finishing
his acceptance speech.
And it will also
show you the method
that we invented to ensure that
speeches are kept fairly brief.
This winner is from
the Czech Republic.
He and his colleagues shared
a prize, an Ig Nobel Prize,
with another team that's
based in the US and India.
And the two of them
each were awarded
because they were
gathering evidence
to answer the question,
is it mentally hazardous
to own a cat?
Here is Jaroslav Flagr.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The attention of both the
general and scientific public
of our discovery of R-- H--
-Please stop.
I'm getting bored.
Please stop.
I'm bored.
-Therefore.
-Please stop.
I'm bored.
-My really important discovery--
-Please stop.
I'm bored.
-The theory of frozen evolution.
Therefore, thank you.
-Please stop.
I'm bored.
-[INAUDIBLE].
You, general public--
-I'm bored.
Please stop.
I'm bored.
-Very, very much.
-Please stop.
I'm bored.
[END VIDEO  PLAYBACK]
MARC ABRAHAMS: We came up
with that device 13 years ago.
And the first year we did that,
the entire Ig Nobel Ceremony
was one hour shorter than
it had been the year before.
And every year, we
have kept pretty
close to finishing on time.
Mostly, thanks to that device.
Here's a quick
look at the winners
that we gave out last year.
The Medicine Prize was awarded
to a team from Japan, China,
and the US for assessing
the effects of listening
to opera on heart transplant
patients who are mice.
[LAUGHTER]
They describe their work in this
paper, "Auditory Stimulation
of Opera Music Induced
Prolongation--."
All of the things
I'm showing you,
you can easily obtain copies.
Or if you can't, email me
and I'll send you a copy.
On our website on
improbable.com,
there's one page that
lists all of the winners,
going back to the very
beginning with links
to most of their
work and all that.
It's usually worth
looking at the work
because we're just giving you
a little, little, tiny summary.
Often, the details
are far better.
And most of these people have
done a lot of other things.
And most of them
who are still alive
are still working on things.
And you know from your own
experience with your colleagues
and-- most of you, quite
probably, with yourself.
People can be very clever
and they don't always
trumpet the news of the best and
worst things that they've done.
So follow some
links if you like.
Here is that team.
They flew in from Japan.
We were not exactly
aware that they
planned to show up
wearing mouse costumes.
And we were not at
all aware that they
planed to then sing their
speech in the form of an opera.
[LAUGHTER]
The Ig Nobel Prize for
Psychology went to a large team
from France, the US, the UK,
the Netherlands, and Poland.
They confirmed by
experiment that people
who think they are drunk also
think they are attractive.
This is their paper.
The title, "Beauty is in the Eye
of the Beer Holder-- People Who
Think They are Drunk also
Think They are Attractive."
This experiment
was done in France.
So it's not firmly known that
this effect happens outside
of France, but they
believe it does.
And here is that
team at the moment
that they were
awarded the prize.
And it's being handed
to them right here.
And then, they, too,
showed up planning
to sing their acceptance
speech, which they did.
You can see-- this
in the Miss Sweetie
Poo, that's what
we call our device.
She's a charming
eight-year-old child
who happens to have
ice water in her veins.
We choose very carefully.
And we need-- since
they tend to grow up,
we need to get a new Miss
Sweetie Poo every year or two.
This is Miss Sweetie
Poo from last year.
We gave a prize in the
field of Safety Engineering.
It went to Gustano Pizzo,
the late Gustano Pizzo,
who lived in New York City.
He won for inventing--
in about 1972 he invented
an electromechanical system
to trap airplane hijackers.
Mr. Pizzo's system worked
by dropping a hijacker
through trapped doors
inside the plane.
And then there
was some machinery
that would seal the
hijacker up into a package.
That package would then
drop through the airplane's
specially-installed
bomb bay doors
and would be
parachuted to earth,
where police, who
were alerted by radio,
would await the arrival of this
packaged hijacker by parachute.
This is the patent
that Mr. Pizzo has.
And you can see more of
his device and his thinking
if you look up the patent.
As far as we know,
this was never
adopted by any of
the major airlines.
At least partially because
it's very expensive
to refit an airplane to have
all these bomb bay doors,
and hijacker encapsulation
devices, and trap doors,
and other things.
The Ig Nobel Prize for
Physics was awarded to a team
from Italy, Russia, and
several other countries.
The work was mostly
done in Italy.
They discovered that
some people would
be physically capable of running
across the surface of a pond
if those people and that
pond were on the moon.
Here's their paper about
it called "Humans Running
in Place on Water at
Simulated Reduced Gravity."
It was published in "PLOS
ONE," a very good journal.
Many of the things that
have won Ig Nobel Prizes
have been published
in top journals.
Many have been published
in bottom journals
and many not published at all.
By the way, it's
not just science.
We can give and do give Ig Nobel
Prizes in pretty much anything.
Most years we give
out a Peace Prize.
We a couple times have
given out an Art Prize.
The first time we gave out
an Ig Nobel Prize in Art,
it went to a man named
Don Featherstone.
He's the creator of the
plastic pink flamingo.
And if you'd come to
the Ig Nobel Ceremony,
you could have met him.
This is some of the work done
about-- what they were trying
to figure out was if
you were to somehow make
the force of gravity
weaker on earth,
how much weaker
would it have to be
before an ordinary
person could walk
across the surface of water?
There are some animals
that can do that.
There are a few lizards
and some insects that
are able to walk across the
surface of water, but not many.
And as it worked out in
the calculations and then
when they did some
experiments, it
turned out that the
surface of the moon
just happens to be
right at the level
where if there were water there,
and you can walk and breathe
and all, you could walk
across that surface.
Here's a little
video they gave us
of how they did that research.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[LAUGHTER]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MARC ABRAHAMS: Being
here at Google,
I imagine you have dozens of
labs filled with people doing
things like this spread across
a hundred different countries.
But maybe that's just my desire.
And here is part
of the team flew in
from Italy to accept the prize.
And you can see them
here finishing up
their acceptance speech.
We give a prize in the
field of Archaeology.
Went to a team from
Canada and the US.
They were awarded their prize
for parboiling a dead shrew.
A shrew, you probably
know, is a small animal
about the size of a mouse.
And it looks fairly
like a mouse.
They parboiled a
dead shrew and then
swallowed that shrew
without chewing it.
They were careful
not to chew it.
And then they carefully
examined everything
excreted by the test
subject who ate that
during the next several days.
They did this so they could
see which bones would dissolve
inside the human
digestive system
and which bones would not.
They published a paper on it.
The paper's called
"Human Digestive Effects
on a Micromammalian Skeleton."
It's got details and
photographs of the work.
And they got a big surprise.
They had expected that the
smallest bones, many of them
would be dissolved.
Some of the medium-sized
bones might suffer some damage
from the digestive juices.
And that the big bones
would be largely intact.
That's not what happened.
What happened was
even the biggest bones
were substantially dissolved.
And they were kind of
shocked to see this.
This was completely against
anybody's expectation.
They don't discuss it
too much in the paper,
but this also could be
a very shocking thing
to an awful lot
of people who are
archaeologists because there
are an awful lot of papers that
have been published for decades
interpreting collections
of bones.
Typically, of some small
animal and some large animal
in the same place,
where it seems evident
that the large animal
ate the small animal.
And an awful lot
of the explanation
that the archaeologists
came up with
had to do with because there
are only these bones left
and these ones are damaged,
the large animal must
have had massive jaws and
a certain kind of teeth.
This paper says that
is not necessarily so.
So it might be
kind of interesting
over the next few
years to see if this
gets noticed in the
archaeology community.
This is the winner at the
moment he was introduced.
And you can see Eliza
Kosoy there helping
to shepherd him through
the sacred curtain.
And if you'd like
to shake her hand
and try to bribe her later,
I'm sure Eliza wouldn't
mind shaking your hand
and trying to be bribed.
For the next one--
the next prize
that I'm going to describe,
if you are tempted
to for any reason, to applaud
this achievement, please
do not.
Please just hold your
applause on this one
no matter how much you
approve, or whatever,
of what this person did.
The Ig Nobel Peace
Prize was awarded
to Alexander Lukashenko,
the President
of the country of Belarus.
He won the Ig Nobel
Peace Prize for making
it illegal to applaud in public.
He shared the Peace Prize
with the Belarus State Police,
who were arrested a
one-armed man for applauding.
Here are some of President
Lukashenko's press clippings
from around the world.
We gave a prize in the
field of Probability.
That Ig Nobel Prize
was awarded to a team
from the UK, the
Netherlands, and Canada.
They're based in
Edinburgh in Scotland.
They won for making two
related discoveries.
First, that the longer a
cow has been lying down,
the more likely that
cow will soon stand up.
[LAUGHTER]
And second, that
once a cow stands up,
you cannot easily predict how
soon the cow will lie down
again.
They published a paper called
"Are Cows More Likely to Lie
Down the Longer They Stand?"
They sent us this
photo of the research.
And this is Bert Tolkamp,
one of the researchers
who flew from
Edinburgh to Cambridge
here to hastily finish
up his acceptance speech
as you can see.
And the Ig Nobel Prize
for Public Health
was awarded to a large team
of doctors in Thailand.
They're all based
at the same hospital
in the city of
Bangkok, Thailand.
They were honored for
the medical techniques
they described in a
report they published.
Their report is called
"Surgical Management
of an Epidemic of Penile
Amputations in Siam."
A "Surgical Management
of an Epidemic
of Penile Amputations in Siam."
They were honored for
those techniques which
they recommend, except in cases
where the amputated penis has
been partially eaten by a duck.
[LAUGHTER]
Here is the beginning of their
paper, which, as you can see,
sure enough is called "Surgical
Management of an Epidemic
of Penile Amputations in Siam."
I would be happy to explain
the duck part if you like.
And if you already
know, that's fine
and I won't waste your time.
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: Do tell.
MARC ABRAHAMS: All right.
There's always one person
who somehow has not
heard the details.
As they explain,
I think lovingly
in this paper for the benefit
of readers outside Thailand,
in Thailand many
people live in houses
that are built on stilts.
And many of those houses--
underneath the house,
the family keeps the farm
animals-- chickens, ducks,
whatever.
There was during the
1970s a true epidemic.
Apparently the first one or
two were publicized heavily
in the newspapers
and this somehow led
to many other people doing
it of angry wives severing
their husband's penis.
Usually, after the
husband had done
much provoking of some sort
the wife would sever the penis.
And then sometimes,
throw it out the window.
And occasionally,
the severed penis,
in its journey
outside the window,
would land down amidst
the farm animals, which
wasn't necessarily
a terrible problem
as far as the surgeons
were concerned.
They were usually able
to reattach the pieces
and get everything working.
Except, they said, in cases
where the piece of meat
had been chewed by a duck.
So was that clear?
So that's a quick look at last
year's Ig Nobel Prize winners.
And we're starting to prepare
for next year's, which
will be the 25th First Annual
Ig Nobel Prize Ceremony.
And I have collected a bunch
of things I've written.
Much of these writings
stemming from the things
that I did in the
newspaper column
in "The Guardian" in this
lovely and delightful book,
which has just come out, called
"This is Improbable Too."
And I had a previous collection
called "This is Improbable,"
thus the "Too."
It got some nice reviews.
It came out in England
a few months ago
and it's come out here
in the US just now.
And in England,
it got one review
that I especially am proud of.
It was a very long review.
And if you write a
book, you're always
grateful when you
get a long review
because there's not that
much space in newspapers.
This was in the biggest
of the London newspapers,
"The Daily Mail,"
which you may know
has a peculiar attitude towards
scientists and technology
and many other things.
But they gave it a long review.
And what I'm proud of
is that they summed up
the book in the midst of
that review in this phrase.
They said that this book
is almost dementedly
inconsequential.
So I hope you enjoy the
book and the other things
I'll be writing about.
I've brought a couple other
issues of the magazine for you,
too.
Should I distribute
them the same way?
OK.
This direction and over here.
Normally, we do distribute
them through the mail.
Or also, in the form of ebooks.
And I should mention we became
one of the first magazines
to publish also in the form
of ebooks, not just paper.
And we did it with
some assistance
from you guys, which I
want to thank you for.
Specifically, Dave [INAUDIBLE]
was very, very helpful.
When we were trying to overcome
some of the limitations
that Amazon for some reason put
into ebooks, making it nearly
impossible to have nicely
formatted documents
in the form of ebooks that
could be sold by ebook vendors,
I was looking around
for several years
trying to find
other publishers who
were trying to find a way
to solve that problem.
And one of the few
people I found,
and one of the
few groups I found
that had been working
on the same problem
was here at Google, Dave
[INAUDIBLE] and his gang.
So they were tremendously
helpful to us
in coming up with this new way.
And if you see
Dave in the halls,
please pass on my
hello and thanks.
That's another picture of
another issue of the magazine.
One issue every year
is a special issue
devoted to the Ig Nobel Winners.
The opera mouse researchers
ended up on the cover.
I want to finish with one
other little piece of video
from the ceremony
a couple weeks ago.
And I'll introduce
it because it, too,
has a connection to you.
You may recognize this
man, Ray Kurzweil.
Ray's title is,
I think, Director
of Engineering,
something like that?
And I worked for Ray
a long time ago back
at Ray's first company,
Kurzweil Computer Products.
I was a programmer.
We were working on optical
character recognition
things and a machine that
read printed things allowed
for blind people and
other related stuff.
But Ray has many
sides, as you may know.
And one of them has
to do with nutrition.
Ray, for decades, has been
working on ideas about people
stopping for the most part
eating what they're eating now
and having a diet
heavily based on hundreds
of carefully selected pills.
And he believes and
has written extensively
that if you follow
the diet properly,
you stand a good chance
of living for, perhaps,
many hundreds of years.
Maybe even beyond that.
So every year in our--
well, not so at that point.
Every year in the Ig Nobel
Ceremony, the heart of it
is when we introduce
the 10 Ig Nobel Winners.
But between those announcements,
we do other things.
And one of the things we do,
the grandest thing we do,
is every year we
write a little opera
about something in science.
We steal music from dead
composers-- Mozart this year--
and we write a story
and lyrics that
explain or don't
explain something going
on now in science
and technology.
This year, it was about--
I took the idea of Ray,
or somebody, subsisting
on nothing but pills
and I twisted that
and extended it
way off into other directions.
And I told Ray.
Invited him to
the ceremony, too.
Although, he didn't come.
And what I'm going to
show you is the very end
of the opera, the last
minute or so of the opera.
The plot, it's two people.
It's two wealthy
entrepreneurs who
follow the idea--
the same one Ray did.
They stop eating
regular food and they
decide to get all their
nourishment entirely
from hundreds and
hundreds of pills.
And they are very greedy
people in this opera.
This is very fictional people.
They are very greedy people.
And they end up buying all
the farmland in the world
because they want to ensure
that they're going to survive.
They do.
After 600 years,
they're still around,
but there are no other people.
It's just them and
their microbes.
And then something goes wrong.
All of their pills have been
stored in their basement
and they've neglected
their plumbing.
And the plumbing broke and
flooded the basement and all
of their pills, all their
food supply is gone.
And they have no skills about
raising food or making pills,
so they're doomed
and they know it.
What you're going to see is the
last minute or so of the opera
when they know they're doomed.
They're still desperately
trying to think
of some way to survive.
And their microbes, who
you will see as a chorus
all around them, are
not at all unhappy
because their microbes are
probably going to survive.
So you're going to see the
two people doomed, panicked,
and their microbes.
A chorus of microbes, which
includes four people who
have Nobel Prizes, who
were kind enough to let us
stick them in the chorus,
all coming together
in this glorious
conclusion to the opera.
The opera is called,
"What's Eating You."
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MARC ABRAHAMS: Ta-dah.
So if you happen
to run into Ray,
you might say hi and offer
him some lunch or something.
That's everything I
brought to show you.
I want to thank you
for inviting me.
And if you have
any questions, I'd
be happy to try to answer them.
So thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: What caused you
to decide to do all this?
MARC ABRAHAMS: What caused
me to decide to do all this?
I was a peculiar little kid.
And most of the pieces
of what I'm doing now I
was doing as a little kid.
I liked to read lots
of science stuff.
And I liked to write what I
thought were funny things.
And I also very early on
started reading newspapers.
And I especially liked
the odd, little stories
that I would see tucked away
in the corners of pages.
Because newspapers
have always had a--
Before the internet, where
space stopped mattering so much,
they always had the problem
that you have to fill the page.
And if you got a corner, you
fill it with something short.
And if you had a
taste for that, you
could notice that
newspapers all the time
would have these odd,
little stories that
were very short and
memorable to me.
So I used to cut those
out and collect those.
And I'm still sort
of doing that.
And then I went off
and studied math
and got involved
with computer stuff
and was doing that because
I didn't think as a grown up
you could get paid or make a
living doing this other stuff.
But I kept doing it
and just giving it
to a couple of friends.
You know, writing things,
collecting things.
And then one day,
I-- by this time,
I had started a little
software company of my own.
But one day I just
started wondering,
could I get some of my
stuff published someplace?
If I send it in to some journal,
can I get something published?
So I sent some of my
stuff off to a journal
with a little cover letter.
And a few weeks later I got
a phone call from somebody
saying, hi, I'm the
publisher of the journal.
Got your articles.
Would you be the
editor of the journal?
[LAUGHTER]
So I went and talked to him.
And I couldn't resist this.
This was the chance
to do all this.
And there was a long
history leading up to then.
That journal had been started
by a couple of scientists
in the 1950s, and it had
gone through tremendous highs
and lows and been
kind of wrecked,
then bought by a big
British science publisher
just at this time.
So it was a kind of
happy conjunction.
So I started doing
that at night.
For the next four years, I
was running my little software
company, doing this at night.
I started the Ig Nobel
Ceremony and all kinds
of mostly good things and many
wonderful things happened.
I've been very happy.
It's been growing and
infecting the world.
And now we have a
big gang of people
all around the world
who seem to devote,
I think in some
cases, maybe too much
of their lives to
being part of this.
But I'm very happy at
the way it's working out.
And I invite all of
you to be part of this.
If you run across
something that you
think people should
know about, just
something that makes
you laugh and makes you
think, then the
favor I ask of you,
in addition to-- thank you
for the favor you granted
of celebrating Dr. Fesmire,
is the next time you
run across something that
really hits you that way,
after you tell your three
best friends about it,
if you want the rest
of the world to know,
just drop me a line.
And I always give people
credit for discovering it,
unless they don't want it.
If you want your name to not
appear, that's absolutely fine.
Just say something.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: So I find what you're
doing to be pretty hilarious.
That said, there's
kind of view or culture
right now where it's
sort of anti-science.
And a lot of views that research
funding is a waste in science.
Do you have any
thoughts about if this
impacts that either way?
MARC ABRAHAMS: Oh, yes.
When we started doing this
stuff, a lot of people
assumed, and they
still-- people new to it
will assume from the
name or something else
that we must be out to trash
scientists, and technology,
and medicine, and
all that stuff.
And no, not at all.
What we're about, at least
what I think we're about,
is trying to tempt people
into being a little more
curious about things.
And also, maybe to
my grand ambition,
to get people a little more
in the habit of when you hear
something, when somebody
important tells you something--
this is great.
This is wonderful,
this discovery.
Or, that medicine is bad or that
video games are bad, whatever.
Or this person is terrible.
That when some important
person tells you something,
you can accept that if you want.
But you can also look at it
and make your own decision.
So the general thing
that I really love--
and I hope this is
what is at work here--
is things that are right on
the edge, where at first glance
it's not possible for
anybody at first glance
to know whether this is a good
or a bad thing, or valuable,
or worthless.
It's just not possible.
You have to look into
it in more detail.
And then it may not
be possible even then.
It may play out over years.
so trying to promote
things in both ends.
For bad stuff--
yeah, I would love
people to look harder at the
bad stuff and realize it's bad.
But on the other
end, I really want
people to look at
everything else
and think that what
you're looking at,
you may be laughing at it.
But that may turn out to
be something you decide
is one of the best parts of
your life a few years from now.
So don't be hasty in
making those judgments.
It's a tough kind of-- and maybe
a crazy thing to want to do,
but that's what I want to do
and that's what we're doing.
So did that answer the question?
Thanks.
OK, well, I won't keep you
from lunch and whatever.
Again, thank you very,
very much for inviting me.
I feel very honored and very
proud and happy to be here.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]